we know you a lot for you very comedy
roles oh we did Saxon
no you fool LED balloon as well
fantastic in those wasn't like in a
comedy horror though how's it compare as
Samedi great fun you know it's it's the
same thing but with guns and blood and
the undead and you know what it
translates so easily the migration is
superb it's easy it's you know in terms
of that but but yeah just just playing
with all those guns and seeing all those
like dead bodies all over the place grim
but funny now you're a premiere aren't
you how did you finding the East and
accent furnace what I do you know what I
love I love doing a bit of this thing
you know it's quite fun like I love I do
a lot of voice acting in you know
cartoon stuff like that so that's my
favorite sort of form of acting really I
love playing with my voice but it was
great do you know what being a bro me
and surrounded by the likes of Alan Ford
and sort of being accepted into that
vocal community was fantastic you know a
lot of fun a lot of funding they tell me
about the relationship of offset with
your brother onset which is played by
hurry Treadaway sky over there
fantastic you know I mean the same with
everybody we all gone really well we had
a great time and it sounds boring to say
but it you know it's the truth like
there's there was a lot of fun just
loads of improv which mateus the
director was kind enough to allow us to
do and yeah just had a blast making it
had an absolute that and I've known
Michelle for some time we did a movie
called almond candy in like 2006 I think
so
we automatically you know picked up
where we left off now we do like to be
doing a lots more movies like this do
you think I would you know of course how
could you not there's zombies and
there's drama and there's love and you
know it's yeah of course I would love to
a sequel if you guys love it and you
should then number two what would you
like to see happen in a sequel huh do
you know what selfishly
kind of like to be a zombie I don't know
I just it was watching all those guys
being did up every morning just I
thought man I'm just I would just love
to be a little bit of a zombie but the
time in the chair was not funny that
scuse me
got a zombie crawling on my nose that's
a weird place for somebody to be you
know like they hide everywhere oh my god
there's one there no it's not how would
you cope in a zombie apocalypse you
think I'd cry a lot I cry a lot I'd I
try and cut them or just aim for the
eyes which is bad I think I did pretty
well yeah you know James has got like a
whole plan works out you should watch
the into you're done with him
you've got a lot of good advice on that
yeah no I it's going to be interesting
it's gonna be interesting I think maybe
the companies will prevail who knows
would you have that weapon of choice if
you were faced with a zombie I would
have a rail gun did you have a favorite
zombie death in the film oh yeah can't
say can't say you got it it's in the
first part that's my favorite that's my
favorite it's some really inventive
deaths and there aren't there were you
surprised I had been through it could be
because we've seen a lot of zombie films
over the years haven't we right and and
and you know what I was surprised at how
inventive and gruesome yet funny they
were and I think that's the ones that
were which 90% of them were my favorite
so yeah this doesn't there might be part
of a jaw being bitten off I'm just
saying I'm just saying Oh Jerusalem I
was like for you now do you know what
I'm doing I'm doing couple of Disney
cartoons and I'm doing the new series of
Dennis the Menace Dennis and Gnasher are
there so yeah going to going to be
continuing on with that until maybe
November time and just on a pilot called
privado where I have chocolate hands so
yeah it's
it's interesting it's fun chocolate it's
a comedy well how does this work it's
quite a dark comedy yeah I'm leaving it
at that it's I heard something about was
it groove hi have you got a TV series as
well called that groove why that's
that's one of the Disney cartoons I play
a bunch of characters in that the Bears
who's kind of like hey how you doing
buddy yeah you know he's one of them
American cool guys you know and Lex and
his sister and it's kind of like a I
don't I don't want to liken it to Glee
but it's the song it's song based and a
lot of cartoon funery but look forward
to that you want loads of things going
on cockneys vs. zombies is a top firm
thanks for taking turns guys cheers
thanks very much
you